showcasing its capabilities Hezbollah
appears to be sending messages of
deterence as Israel threatens all out
War this video is set to show a
Precision guided missile striking what
the Lebanese armed group says was an
Israeli surveillance Dome at an Army
Post on the
border Hezbollah is also firing other
explosive missiles as the crossb
fighting triggered by Israel's war on
Gaza escalates it's been targeting
military sites few kilometers inside
Israel we warn you against turning your
aggression toward Lebanon because what
awaits you are Graves if you only felt
the partial power of our organization
then in all out War you will taste our
full power we are well prepared for war
the Israeli Army also says it is
prepared for a fullblown war recent war
games in Northern Israel also involved
simulated fighting in urban areas and in
winter weather all the while the Israeli
Army has been increasing the intensity
of its attacks on Hezbollah and its
infrastructure in southern
Lebanon but a US Envoy involved in
trying to prevent a bigger conflict says
there's still a window for diplomacy
Amos hon says he will likely head back
soon to Beirut and T Aviv to work on
first a sensation of hostilities that
will allow people on both sides sides of
the border to return home and then a
more lasting solution Beyond a ceasefire
that would involve a beefed up presence
of Lebanese Army troops in southern
Lebanon and the demarcation of the land
border Hezbollah has tied this front to
a permanent ceasefire in Gaza and that's
why diplomacy and military action have
failed to push its forces away from the
border they are trying to use the US
mediation to pressure the government and
hasah to accept their demands to uh to
keep hasbalah away from from the border
hasbalah is maintaining that uh uh the
war the fire in Gaza should be announced
before we move forward so I think
there's a diplomatic uh uh pressure
pressure from both side but it doesn't
seem that any of them is interested in a
uh in a conflict at this point for now
Israel's Focus appears to be eliminating
what it calls the threat in southern
Lebanon Zen Al jaaz
beut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer